et
[Musique]
gégène le maître de la terre est devenu
l'ami des jbe les jbe lui font de la
musique gégène déchaîne les éléments
tous les matins gégène projet chez les
giboulées et la fête recommençait
[Musique]
autrefois c'était les jpy qui allait
chez gégène pour lui faire des concerts
à domicile et lui donner l'aubade à
titre d'information disons que le
domicile de juges n était évidemment
souterrain mais confortable on y
trouvait en particulier une salle de
bain pour le lundi une salle de bain
pour le mardi une pour le mercredi et le
jeudi 2 pour le vendredi et c'est comme
ça pour tous les jours de l'année
venait ensuite une garde-robe avec tracy
broom chapeau rouge chaussures ou mot
cravate rouge et parapluies rouges une
kitchenette salle à manger salon chambre
à coucher bibliothèque et enfin une
grande ont très très perfectionnés étant
donné qu'elle pouvait aussi servir pour
sortir avec en plus naturellement un
grenier et un vaste gare de mantes et où
ça gène bt des shadoks qu'il avait
récupéré mais tout ça servait pas à
grand chose car dès qu'il était réveillé
il allait écouter la musique jpy et ça
lui plaisait tellement
et aussi jouer d'un instrument l'après
midi comme d'habitude il le faisait sa
sieste est là lui évidemment il se
repose et tout le monde était content
les châteaux pendant ce temps la main on
profitait pour parfaire leur éducation
et mettait sur pied le faste plomb
d'organisation rationnelle de la terre
pour en faire une planète à leur
convenance serait pouvait se demande ce
que ça allait donner
[Musique]